right so my talk at the table is
lawmakers and health officials asking
the FDA to investigate the energy drink
Prime so if you're not familiar the
drink is backed by influencers and
YouTube Stars Logan Paul and KSI now it
has been a favorite drink among their
young fans the official's concern is
prime contains 200 milligrams of
caffeine and each 12 ounce can as much
as six cans of Coke or two cups of two
cups of coffee or two red bulls Prime
has been banned in some schools and in
Britain in Australia after doctors warn
the high caffeine content could cause
heart problems and anxiety and digestive
issues in kids CBS News asked Prime for
a statement we have not heard back I
just think it's interesting because we
do stories about influencers using their
platform to sell their products
rightfully so do your thing but when
you're selling products that could be
harmful especially to your young fan
base yes you know we gotta we got to
talk about so I'm pretty sure the can
has a little warning on there not for
not intended for 18 and under that
nobody yeah but why no one reads but I
mean it would it would it would make a
difference if if Logan Paul and the
other backers made a bigger point of
that of course it would help of course
no doubt